[Musica]
ora nella primavera del 2018 un signore
ha scritto una lettera che di per sé non
è una gran notizia con cui iniziare ma è
più interessante sapere che questo
signore ha scritto questa lettera seduto
su 9.000 miliardi di dollari una cifra
grande
perché questo signore è larry fink è il
capo l'amministratore delegato di black
rock che è il più grande fondo di
investimenti del mondo per capirci il
fondo che possiede un bel pezzo
dell'economia
mondiale e questo signore ha deciso di
prendere carta e penna e scrivere ai
suoi colleghi capi importantissime
aziende di tutto il mondo immaginatevi
dei più importanti che vi vengono in
mente e ha scritto loro
guardate da domani mattina se volete i
soldi di blackrock se volete che noi
investiamo nelle vostre imprese
presentatevi qua con un bella con una
bella documentazione che mostri quanto e
quale impatto sociale ambientale
dimostrate questa cosa il contenuto di
questa lettera non è straordinariamente
emozionante
è emozionante che non l'abbia scritto un
economista sociale un filantropo un
anarchico la scritta un signore che è
proprio un finanziere di quelli veri di
quelli che fanno quel mestiere lì e
quindi la grande domanda è perché l'ha
fatto perché ha deciso di prendere carta
penna e dare questo messaggio così forte
e qui abbiamo tante interpretazioni
perché un mattino si è svegliato buono
perché ha sentito nell'aria che era il
momento giusto di farlo per opportunismo
perché forse passeggiava per con la sua
famiglia per san francisco si è reso
conto che di cento persone che
incontrava uno era un miliardario 10
erano homeless o che se si alzava ancora
un po l'oceano gli asset finanziari
immobiliari le case che possedeva lungo
la costa della california
non valevano più niente
insomma l'ha fatto perchè l'ha fatto a
noi interessa che l'abbia fatto
perché è stato un momento molto
significativo nella consacrazione della
sostenibilità all'interno dei sistemi
economici e da lì sono successe tante
cose per esempio l'elite della
confindustria mondiale e americana ha
scritto un documento ha rilasciato un
documento in cui la sapete il profitto è
quella storia che vi abbiamo raccontato
che massimizzare il profitto per gli
azionisti era l'unica cosa che dovevamo
fare una cosa giusta per tutti
ecco forse ci siamo un po sbagliati e
dobbiamo un po ripensare la nostra
nazione di profitto se vogliamo
fronteggiare quei problemi sociali
ambientali che stanno cominciando a
diventare realmente insostenibile e poi
altre cose tra l'altro due quotidiani
che non sono proprio come dire gli house
organ dell'economia sociale
dell'economia ambientale financial time
l'economist hanno cominciato a titolare
dobbiamo ripensare il capitalismo
rifondiamo il capitalismo una bravissima
ricercatrice ha scritto ripensare il
capitalismo nel mondo che va a fuoco è
insomma la sostenibilità e l'impegno
delle imprese e delle organizzazioni
finanziarie per la sostenibilità
ambientale e sociale è cresciuto è
cresciuto e siamo arrivati a febbraio
del 2000 e 20 febbraio 2020 avevamo già
un mezzo passo nel piede nella pandemia
però c'è la world economic forum a davos
e a davos è stata tutta una grande
sfilata di nuovo dei grandi capitalisti
del mondo che dicevano
per la mia impresa è fondamentale essere
sostenibile il mio fondo di investimenti
fei e solo cose sostenibili la mia
impresa un ruolo straordinario
nell'arginare il cambiamento climatico
nessuna menzione alla pandemia e quindi
in quel momento c'era un impegno enorme
delle imprese di tutti gli attori
economici a fare cose per contrastare il
cambiamento climatico i problemi
ambientali problemi sociali le
diseguaglianze e il sottotitolo di
questo impegno bisognava leggerlo bene
perché era anche un po caro stato fatti
ancora un po più da parte non è solo più
che non ci serve per regolare i
meccanismi economici non ci servi dentro
l'economia
adesso non ci serve più neanche tanto
per le cose negative per i difetti che
escono dai sistemi economici quindi per
l'ambiente per le diseguaglianze
facciamo noi
portiamo dentro però il nostro modo di
essere agenti economici dentro
l'economia
dei modi di agire che risolveranno anche
questi problemi poi in realtà è venuta
la pandemia c'eravamo già quasi dentro e
durante la pandemia al mondo si è
capovolto si è capovolta al punto che di
nuovo lo stato e sta e tornato ad essere
stato la politica pubblica è tornato ad
essere centrale fondamentale ci siamo
rivolti allo stato per salvarci la vita
per uscire dalla situazione dal dramma
sanitario e anche ci rivolgiamo allo
stato per chiedere aiuto all'economia
quegli stessi attori si rivolgono lo
stato per chiedere aiuto per uscire
dalla crisi economica che purtroppo
forse stiamo solo vedendo iniziare
e quindi il pendolo è oscillato
paurosamente dall'altra parte adesso era
lo stato
e allora tra ruolo dello stato e anche
quell'economia di emergenza quella
narrativa da economia di guerra che è
esplosa subito
salviamoci la pelle chi se ne importa
dei problemi climatici che verranno
chi se ne importa le diseguaglianze
adesso dobbiamo tirarci fuori di qua
c'era il timore che questa appunto
litanie da economia di guerra diciamo
togliesse la sostenibilità mettesse la
parte la sostenibilità
l'imperativo della sostenibilità e che
della sostenibilità avremmo ricominciato
a parlare tra 4 5 anni a emergenza
dimenticata
e invece non è successo per fortuna non
è successo perché la pandemia ci ha
ricordato un'altra cosa importantissima
che è la centralità e l'importanza della
reciprocità dei beni relazionali del
mutualismo della cooperazione delle
comunità della prossimità e ce l'ha
ricordato in un modo che a qualcuno come
a me ha fatto ricordare una cosa che un
signore che si chiama karpol anni aveva
scritto nel 1942
lo dico perché non è un caso che
l'avesse scritto
durante
l'altra crisi mondiale paragonabile a
quella che abbiamo stiamo vivendo che
era la seconda guerra mondiale e non a
caso l'ha scritto in un libro che si
intitola la grande trasformazione
attualissimo in cui dice sostanzialmente
c'è una terza via c'è un modo di
interagire degli esseri umani nelle
comunità nella reciprocità che si può
dedicare un'altra via e quindi in realtà
la sostenibilità non è affatto uscita
dalla prospettiva degli attori economici
e quindi anche degli individui ma è
diventata un imperativo assoluto
e quindi abbiamo vinto e quindi la
partita è finita no non è affatto finita
e finito il primo tempo è finito il
primo tempo nel quale noi abbiamo vinto
la battaglia della droga si per la
sostenibilità abbiamo vinto la battaglia
che serviva per mettere al centro la
sostenibilità nei discorsi di tutti e
oggi è proprio così se noi entriamo in
una qualunque impresa in un qualunque
fondo gli investimenti uniamo investiti
da una comunicazione norme anzi diciamo
pure oggi è difficilissimo quasi
impossibile trovare uno che non sia
verde e sostenibile attento alle
diseguaglianze
ma questo è solo il primo tempo
adesso sta iniziando il secondo tempo in
cui c'è una cosa molto più importante in
gioco è quello che in gioco e che cosa
ci mettiamo dentro a questo termine
sostenibilità a come lo interpretiamo
come lo agiamo e qui purtroppo
l'esito non è affatto scontato e per
questo io dico il fatto che oggi tutti
stiamo parlando di sostenibilità io sono
molto contento sono felice ma non è
necessariamente una buona notizia
quello che conta è che cosa ne sarà di
questa sostenibilità e ci sono due esiti
possibili
uno è che questo afflato alla
sostenibilità sia qualcosa di
trasformativo di generativo di radicale
di rivoluzionario che fa ripensare gli
attori economici nel profondo loro di
stand modo sta del di stare sul mercato
oppure c'è un altro esito possibile
purtroppo devo dirvi secondo me non solo
possibile anche più probabile che questo
sia un'operazione di conservazione di
protezione delle rendite di posizione
di conservazione dello status quo
e allora oggi la partita vera e lavorare
per il primo esito e non per il secondo
come si fa a cosa si fa tante cose
naturalmente la prima e la più
importante dell'energia l'impegno che
tutti stiamo cercando di mettere in
questa direzione l'altra però e fare
attenzione ai falsi amici oa gli ex
amici
durante la il primo tempo quando tutti
cercavamo di imporre la sostenibilità ci
hanno accompagnati delle cose come la
responsabilità sociale d'impresa
il bilancio sociale
gli obiettivi delle nazioni unite
i criteri che qualcuno chiama isg
ambientali sociali e di governo delle
imprese ecco quelle così li stanno
diventando i nostri nemici stanno
diventando fuoco amico perché perché lo
sono lo strumento che distrae la nostra
attenzione sull'obiettivo centrale e in
qualche modo ci fa aderire a una visione
leggera poco trasformativa un po
farlocca della sostenibilità perché noi
non abbiamo bisogno di imprese che alla
fine del loro modello modo di stare sul
mercato del loro modello di business
facciano il conto di quanto impatto
positivo hanno generato noi abbiamo
bisogno di imprese che nel loro piano
industriale prima di fare i piani ci
diano degli obiettivi di impatto sociale
e allora che cosa dobbiamo fare se
questi sono un sono più gli amici i
compagni di strada che dobbiamo usare
cosa dobbiamo fare un'altra cosa
dobbiamo chiedere agli agenti economici
di essere intenzionali misurabili e
addizionali intenzionali cosa vuol dire
quello che vi dicevo noi abbiamo bisogno
non più del bilancio sociale abbiamo
bisogno del piano industriale e sociale
non abbiamo più bisogno della
rendicontazione ambientale abbiamo
bisogno di metriche e obiettivi che
specifichino gli obiettivi ambientali e
che siano inseriti nel modo di
funzionare delle imprese quello che
qualcuno chiama il core business poi
abbiamo bisogno di metri che
naturalmente di metriche che siano forti
e chiare tanto quanto sono le metriche
economiche perché altrimenti se noi
incorporeremo gli obiettivi di
sostenibilità nelle organizzazioni
economiche e avremo due metri che una
economica i bilanci delle imprese che a
cent'anni di storia che ai
commercialisti gli standard contabili è
fortissima e delle metriche ambientali e
sociali deboli per forza il sistema
economico
ritornerà immediatamente occuparsi solo
delle degli obiettivi economici quindi
abbiamo bisogno di metriche forti
abbiamo bisogno di metriche equilibrate
oggi le metriche sono fortemente se
sbilanciate sugli obiettivi ambientali e
fanno finta di non cogliere che ci sono
degli obiettivi di diseguaglianza
sociali
fortemente integrati con questa insomma
noi abbiamo bisogno di metriche che si
facciano essere trasformati vi e poi
abbiamo dobbiamo essere addizionali ecco
addizionali e poi il punto caldo di
questa questione addizionali significa
che gli attori economici devono essere
un po disposti ad accettare dei
rendimenti un po più bassi di quelli che
sarebbero spiegati dal rischio che
stanno correndo oppure di correre dei
rischi un po più alti rispetto alla
remunerazione che hanno con i rendimenti
e che cos'è che li compensa di questi
rischi un po più alti e questi
rendimenti un po più bassi l'impatto
sociale ambientale
misurabile questo significa
sostenibilità rivoluzionaria
trasformativa e che cosa vuol dire per
noi è che cosa ha a che fare col
coraggio significa questo io fino a un
anno fa come studioso come ricercatore
chiamatemi come volete
pensavo mi alzavo al mattino pensando
che il mio dovere fosse fare il
buttadentro quello che accompagnava le
persone verso l'obiettivo della
sostenibilità
ecco io credo che oggi il nostro
obiettivo sia fare i buttafuori dire
alle persone che non sono sostenibili
non per fare il censo quando non lo sono
naturalmente non per fare il censore
della sostenibilità ma perché noi
abbiamo un bene supremo da proteggere
che l'integrità dell'impatto sociale
ambientale perché l'integrità
dell'impatto sociale ambientale e
l'unica cosa che ci da quella forza
trasformativa sui sistemi economici su
un clima sull'ambiente e sulla società
che ci serve per contrastare le grandi
sfide del futuro
[Musica]